last week when I was in New Orleans
Louisiana for Netroots nation I reported
to you that the online streaming service
Spotify removed some episodes of Alex
Jones podcast for violations of their
Community Guidelines content guidelines
in terms of service we also reported
that Facebook and YouTube have sort of
sporadically been pulling some
individual pieces of Alex Jones content
off the air and then this morning I woke
up to the news that Apple has made the
decision to remove all Alex Jones and
Infowars content from iTunes which is of
course one of the biggest audio
streaming and podcasting services in the
world the entire library is being
removed and piggybacking on this we also
learned this morning that Spotify and
Facebook will be removing even more Alex
Jones content from their libraries so
let's go through this piece by piece
question one was anything of value lost
is anything of value lost by the removal
of Alex Jones content from different
places on the internet the answer is an
emphatic no no absolutely not
is this censorship of Alex Jones well
let's think about that he can still
produce the show right so not being on
iTunes has no impact on whether he can
get up put his pants on one leg at a
time or maybe jumping into both legs at
once I wouldn't presume to know how Alex
Jones puts his pants on go into wearing
pants maybe he's not even asked there
you don't see even below the desk go
into his studio and do his show no he
can still produce the show he can
distribute it on his own servers if he
wants I don't know that that's something
that he does and he can put the content
anyplace that will have him now do I
understand why he would call it
censorship the answer is yes would I be
saying the same things if iTunes banned
the David Pakman show
I probably would but what we have to
think about here is is there a double
standard and on the one hand claiming to
be a free market libertarian minded
individual who wants businesses to have
the opportunity and the right and the
the ability to make decisions that they
want to make about their platform which
they built with their money right
ultimately that's what Apple did
iTunes or do we say that they should be
forced to host Alex Jones's content and
part of the problem with Jones
specifically is that he's a conspiracy
theorist who partially makes money
saying claiming that everybody wants to
suppress his speech because they don't
want the ultimate truths he's telling to
get out there
when iTunes then pulls him off I think
it definitely bolsters that narrative
with his audience of course you've got a
conspiracy theorist their content gets
singled out for removal that becomes
evidence of the conspiracy to suppress
the dangerous truths that Alex Jones is
willing to tell the reality is the
content isn't being pulled off iTunes or
wherever because it's conspiratorial
it's being removed because it's against
Apple's hate-speech guidelines
Facebook's explanation is similar not
conspiracies but glorifying violence
using dehumanizing language to refer to
people who are transgender Muslim and
immigrants Spotify now removing all Alex
Jones content says it's because he is
expressly and principally promoting
advocating or inciting hatred or
violence against the groover individual
based on characteristics so the question
for me is more about what is legally
okay for these companies to do I don't
think anyone would argue that any of
these companies are doing anything that
is sort of against the law or certainly
not a violation of the First Amendment
because we're not talking about the
government and then we can start
thinking about is there anything that
makes content publishing platforms
different right could you say that
because Spotify and Facebook and YouTube
have massive curation power that it's a
form of suppressing speech I don't know
that's certainly the case that the
defenders of Alex Jones are going to
make I actually don't know how it took
this long for Jones to become a
liability on these platforms right I
mean the Sandy Hook truth or stuff Pizza
gage only now the platforms are saying
we're gonna pull them off I guess it's
probably partially because of public
outcry yeah and I mean he's been saying
crazy stuff for a long time but it's
getting worse and worse I feel like
after Sandy Hook would be the time to do
it right
I was thinking of an analogy to what
Alex Jones has been doing and I thought
let's say I want to write a book
right and I've mentioned I've thought
about writing a book I've talked to
literary agents I would need a publisher
for the book or I can choose to
self-publish which would be sort of like
Alex Jones saying well I'm gonna put the
content on my own servers so nobody can
pull it off of there if I bring the book
to 50 publishers and they all say no we
don't want to publish it are my ideas
being suppressed do I have any right to
be published by a publisher who
publishes other political books I think
the answer is obviously no now you might
hear me make that analogy and say David
that's different a book publisher makes
individual deals with writers Spotify
Facebook YouTube whoever these are
platforms where the default is anybody
can make an account and upload stuff so
with publishing of a book it's a
decision decision to publish that the
business makes with Facebook and YouTube
and Spotify and iTunes they're making
the decision to say we're gonna remove
Alex Jones content and that's a
different situation I think it's a
distinction without a relevant
difference
it was Rand Paul who said something
about single-payer health care would
make doctors slaves or something like
that right because they would have to
work because they would have to cover
everyone everybody yeah they didn't have
to be doctors if they don't want to they
can choose another job so then the
analogy from what Rand Paul said here is
are you enslaving iTunes if you force
them to host Alex Jones's content you
can't really make the argument rand paul
made without applying the same logic to
Spotify or iTunes or Facebook and also
interesting of course is that the same
people who simultaneously argue
businesses should be able to do whatever
they want as long as it's not illegal
they should be able to you know it
should be legal to discriminate against
people on the basis of their sexual
orientation real or perceived for
example but they should be forced to
host Alex Jones content that doesn't
really make sense to me they should be
able to deny a gay person service but
you're forced to publish Alex Jones as
pizza gate rantings and Sandy Hook
truther ISM I would actually make the
case that since being gay isn't a choice
but
being of violence and citing conspiracy
theorist is business should be allowed
to discriminate against violence
inciting conspiracy theorists way before
they should be allowed to discriminate
against gay people but that's I think
going a little bit deeper than maybe the
Alex the specifics of the Alex Jones
situation warrant if you disagree with
me and I know from the messages I was
getting on Twitter earlier today there
are people who believe I am being
hypocritical here but if it was me being
targeted that I would have a different
view that maybe because I would have a
very emotional response but if I'm
violating Terms of Service aren't I just
violating Terms of Service if you
disagree with me let me know this is
also being discussed on the David Pakman
show
subreddit at david pakman.com slash re d
di t discuss it there we will take a
quick break and be back with plenty more
right after this
I am thrilled to tell you that today's
episode is sponsored in part by Blink
accom slash Pakman Blink astiz a really
unique service for your phone tablet and
web browser and it is incredibly useful
for people like me who love books and
learning but are busy blinka steaks the
best and most popular non-fiction books
and condenses them into 15-minute
audiobooks I'm sure that if you're like
me you have a very long list of books
that you've been meaning to read you
only have so many hours in the day and
that's why blink astiz so amazing they
take the most important information the
themes the insights from each book and
they distill it into a 15 minute audio
book that you can listen to in one
sitting I've listened to a ton of books
on blink as' our audience can get a
seven day free trial by going to blink
is calm slash Pakman if you're watching
on youtube i've put a link in the
description i have listened to blink ax
spokes about economics about political
science about history about science so
many interesting things and after the
free trial if you like it you can
continue enjoying thousands of condensed
audiobooks for about 5 bucks a month go
to Blaine
kiss calm / Pakman that's bli nki st.com
/pa que ma n